[Music]
you hosted the season finale of Star not
live that's a big honor I loved it I
loved it usually like the experience I
loved it it went by in a blur it was so
fast and I remember talking to you about
what when you host it and when you were
at SNL and you described it as when
you're there you see pictures from the
original days with John Belushi and
everything and those photos seem like
they're just from the Civil War days you
know yeah I'm so much they really do
they look like there are black-and-white
photographs on the walls of yeah no and
when I got there the show had been on
the air for like 14 years yeah I think
when I got there yeah and they're all
getting ready for the 15th anniversary
and I would walk the halls and look at
the pictures of Belushi and Aykroyd and
I in the Coneheads and I'd say well this
shows coming to an end those old photos
and go man look next with the very
beginning and now we're at the end yeah
and here it is like 80 years later still
going more flow no wrong yeah you were
cast members newer writers I loved it
did you find it weird walking through
the doors at the beginning you know when
you come out to do the monologue yes
because that's the feeling that I that
completely that I didn't expect but it
completely freaked me out which is I had
work I'd grown up watching the show
literally grown up watching it yeah
then I was there and I worked as a
writer and then I left and I worked on
The Simpsons and did other stuff that I
did the late night show and then they
brought me back and they said you want
to host some yeah and they were like
here he comes and I went through those
doors and I'm like this is weird
[Applause]
it is true it was like they put me in
her and you can see I come through the
door and I'm like I'm one of those what
holy something's gone wrong that little
stairway and everything and you don't
behind that door it just looks like a
little set it looks like a fake door oh
it's incredibly depressing yeah yeah
that's the thing you should know about
show businesses it's all like this out
front but backstage like just before our
guests come out there's like a urinal a
guy like a cigarette like you better get
out then be funny and don't touch the
urinal you should get on your audition
to get on stand out live you did an
impression who was your impression of I
did um Sam Waterston Frank we have a
yeah we have here yeah Sam Waterston
there he is he he also plays the eagle
on Sesame Street so so he's no what does
an impression him you did an impression
of him figure yeah and it's the same
stage where I we did you know for the
SNL monologue it's like that same place
you come out and I did him and he's kind
of like he shakes a little bit
the trial judge heard testimony and so
did mr. muñoz
like he's about to cry on the edge yeah
definitely and then you know it got me
got me the job so thank you Sam waters
yeah
you